hello guys
I am Ryan the right and I'm Jessica
Villarreal Jessica Villarreal from best
game show ever fun youtube channel
gaming related we're gonna check out
today top 5 in video games this video
better be really not super censored
oh I know oh yes that's for sure it's
all about HBO
[Music]
yeah
Mark's far cry 3
Grand Theft Auto copy
[Music]
Oh
while she's cutting soldier
[Music]
very comfortable me next here
oh damn Oh every day oh man this is
Steve coming yeah yeah was that like the
ultimate orgasm Wow
man he's a womanizer 8 and 3 y super
handsome
oh good hip movement he knows how to use
his hips what there's more sex on the
streets
[Music]
okay this one was pretty insane
the game far cry
I know what happens when you trust her
[Music]
all the Witcher mature my part dopes
well I'm not it's pretty awesome yeah
that's not my girlfriend undress
[Music]
Oh romantic epic music for HBO music for
some [__] like that Wow okay good good
for them good for them
top five say that's Lou you know top
five it's a mass effect areeyou played
that right yeah I played one two and
three and you're not you weren't the
biggest fan of three I wasn't the
biggest fan of three but on my heart
belonged to liara okay yeah so I roam
ants Liara in you know the first and the
second and the lair of the Shadow Broker
DLC and I honestly don't even remember
what I did in I know if the fact three
everything you're talking about right
now all your layout everything you're
saying
I am so we're on the same page are we on
the same page I'm the same Liara page
she was my shoes my boo I loved her and
I couldn't I couldn't cheat on her so
you know I stayed faithful to her so I
don't know who this Samantha Trainor
[__] is but she's no Liara so they're
lesbians in this game here well you can
play as a male Shepard or a female
Shepard
and so in this case they chose female
Shepard when she's a lesbian
but she can romance other women she can
romance men and aliens you know I gotta
say okay last me and stuff pretty hot
but what can they really do in the
shower anything they want help it's like
okay I get they can do like they can't
have sex though in the shower why not
well don't you have to like rub your
vagina up against another to bed you
know you don't have to rub your did I
know again there's multiple ways to for
lesbians yes really that's the only
impression I got
well maybe they weren't even having sex
maybe it was like about to start because
they did like pan out as they were like
making out I was just like what can how
do this
I mean I know they can do other stuff
it's just the beginning of it so you
know maybe it was just the the seduction
foreplay but I'm not what position would
they didn't you know what we're not
gonna go into this second one was God of
War Kratos Kratos Wow yeah he's just
like Law of Attraction alike right all
these different woman you just kept
piling on in and all of the god of War's
there's always you know Georgie a secret
sex scene yeah
what's great about Kratos though is that
he'll bang all these hot chicks but his
heart only belongs to one the woman he
accidentally killed in a blind rage
that's why he's gray because he was
punished for killing his wife and his
daughter and their ashes stained him
that gray color forever as a constant
reminder of what he did so that's why
he's so [__] pissed
why she's such a Pinto because he's
powerful I guess those women are
attracted to power I suppose man I get
it in my single days I was like
attracting attracting women i orgasm or
just lice and everywhere you go and all
right yeah and I'm like get away from me
[__] yeah wait like how Kratos is
yeah
[__] [__] yeah he's like I'm done
see Kratos is attracting women who have
really bad father issues and don't
believe don't think they're worthy
enough to find someone to be in love
with right so what they do is they just
let their sexuality just take control
and just waste it and just give it up to
anybody because they don't have enough
self-worth towards them
I was not saying if you want to be
promiscuous that means somebody's wrong
I'm just these women clearly have trauma
well I think he killed all of the men
that's why they're just like oh he's the
only man left might as well get our
kicks in while we can still kick Wow
they're all dead he kills everyone in
this game if I was Kratos he kills
everyone if I was Kratos I would
impregnate one girl in every state of
America I don't think he lives in
America I think he does I think he might
be in front of the camera right now yep
sitting right next to you you never know
never not The Witcher 2 which The
Witcher 2 wow that game I saw there in
part 3 or was it - I camera which one it
was where they do it on horse that's
part 3 a spark times in the Conan
O'Brien yeah clueless gamer segments
what what are you
it was it on a real horse or was it like
a stuffed worse that's a good question I
can't remember because that's just rude
to the animal I know
yeah like I wouldn't have sex with my
cat on the bed I know it's like you're
gonna make that horse motion sick or
something yeah it's like my words just
like grazing eating grass nobody knows
and then two people that's heavy
that's almost 300 pounds if each person
weighed 150 pounds which if you know
he's a warrior he's probably a little
more than that and so that horse back
what was cool about him though in the
wisher what in this clip was he looked
like he was gonna make love everyone
else is like oh [__] he was like you
know what I'm gonna be I'm gonna take my
time he's gonna use some Lube
yeah even though there's water yes still
gonna apply Lube as if it's not gonna
come off right but that's okay points
for trying bro way to connect not thanks
guys for tuning in to the channel this
was fantastic I had a great time
watching this video it really means a
lot here and there if you're new to the
channel that doesn't matter
that doesn't matter I say never think
only feel goddamn farm life yeah okay
and so if you're new subscribe today and
become a reject and you can check it out
Jessica Villarreal on best game show
ever
YouTube channel all gaming related check
it out it's actually like good quality
content thank you
Chris Molina what's up Ryan and rejects
i watch her guys videos on a daily and
love the laughter and humor in them
starting a gaming YouTube channel was
pretty hard that's what she dot dot dot
said to the head I'm not even gonna say
it
tongue emoticon and will love a shout
out so shadow thinks keep at it
Chris the Nemesis all right we'll check
out your channel we'll check out your
channel so far you got 21 followers it's
21 people not that every leader starts
somewhere huh playing Fallout 4 ok very
calm let's see what your videos are like
let's see what your videos are like
robots bears rats and death claws
ok ok ok videos not loading but what I
can tell so far from your channel not
enough nudity so he's doing less place
that's ok now what you want to do is
like so many people are doing Let's
Plays nowadays so many people are doing
Let's Plays you want to do something
different like do a let's play but I
don't know I had this idea for a game
that was a porno and it was RPG style so
you could choose how to do things and I
think if you invented that game and you
played it it would go places so not to
just give away my ideas but oh yeah you
know we have a very unique let's play on
best game show ever basically we took
all of our guests and told them that
they were gonna be playing Mario Kart in
the oculus rift and when they sat down
and put the oculus rift on we actually
put them in alien isolation Wow their
reactions and gameplay footage of us
tricking our friends who were such great
sports and it made for one of our you
know like the best season finale of best
game show ever wow it's pretty funny too
it's pretty [__] funny I'm not gonna
lie
Jessica I'm doing shoutouts a Christmas
emesis right now and you're taking this
time out to promote your lives that is
you know I'm sharing and giving you
asked for a unique way to do a let's
play so I wanted to say here's an idea
and your idea was to promote yourself I
guess it was you know what sometimes
you've got to learn to let the spotlight
shine on someone else for a sec sorry
Chris nemesis I'll say it again Chris
the Nemesis forgive me please